[Music]
how's it going all right we're back with
South Park the stick of truth it's back
to its rightful belongs yes
great job men douche bag for your heroic
deeds and valiant self-sacrifice at the
great battle of the giggling donkey I
hereby make you an official member of
the kingdom of Koopa keep welcome to the
KKK what a great honor it's getting late
the grand wizard needs to go night-night
okay mom thanks for pointing out bedtime
for everyone it's a school night hon you
and your little druid friends need we're
not doing math we're [ __ ] warriors
and wizards oh that's it you're going to
bed the rest of you better get home to
[Music]
so it's nighttime now huh so I that's
cool a new quest it's late
well there he is you make any new
friends sweetheart
oh yeah by like five yeah nothing to say
huh
what a surprise it's late sweetie go on
up to bed and I'll be there to say good
night I communicate with my farts I
thought we established this go on to bed
sweetie I'll be up to take good night
that's a beautiful cat hi guys all right
hi fishy get this here alright let's go
to bed good night little man I hope
you're as happy as we are everything is
going to be better now that we're in
this quiet little mountain town dank
meme I thought it was a scar as I'm Jen
oh god what's gonna happen now
no no the aliens I love how he's
slightly cross-eyed
[Music]
okay why are we gonna fight on the
spaceship or something I'm having the
dream a good happening Oh what the [ __ ]
Jesus Jesus Christ oh can we try the big
silver one again oh no not in my body
please I poop from Eric Oh God oh no
don't
No is this your first time getting
probed yeah it's a pain but this is the
kind of stuff you put up with living in
a remote little mountain town at least
we don't have to deal with traffic hey
you broke free kid you have an
incredible control of your [ __ ] get
me loose - I love Stan's mom and dad I
mean he's so awesome
but that thing went inside my eyes and
that's a little discouraging to be
honest ed Garret what do you want from
me seriously
all right so how did we break free with
our [ __ ] or what okay oh yeah this
one I died
you must have broke off part of the
probe and now you can control it with
your sphincter muscles pretty cool you
mean my [ __ ] is that what you're
trying to say so I guess it's connected
to those things cuz I seen them scatter
it all there wait let me let me take a
look at this
don't turn that way I'm trying to look
at it is that it surrounded by some kind
of force field
go find a way to shut it off when you
break me free I can show you how to get
off the ship how do you know that
Ilene helmet
I'm gonna be sore tomorrow what the hell
man hi there the control room okay
that's pretty stupid huh bus yeah so how
the [ __ ] do I get to the [ __ ] control
room talk oh there's a teleporter okay
and see that why should I help with
myself I guess I should fight them mumu
oh yeah me all right let's show these
aliens when we yeah I want one that
affects all of them I guess I don't have
that
oh damn the hell are come on
Hungarian power mow my ass
I got damn the healing [ __ ] space
medicine why what am I the bow is so
good holy [ __ ]
Amy and rate what oh it looks like a
huge dildo that's as much as I like to
use nearly until though that's the lumps
of containment block take that elevator
next to you the probe in your [ __ ]
should interface with it okay there we
go
it's great to have your ass all coming
great news you're looking for a security
console should be one above you improve
maintenance and another below you in the
atmosphere processor do I know this
stuff can't remember which one you want
though been a while since I did this
fantastic been a while
what why Tim Bob huh puberty hit and
your testicles have dropped from your
chin fantastic alright let's keep going
[Music]
that seemed to work someone here okay I
guess we need to go upstairs okay I can
go here cool
there we go maybe I can follow yeah
come you too I want to find on you too I
could say whatever I don't know why I
say for some reason every minute of
every one of them thinking there'd be
some useful information but it's like
they're just loving way something
okay so now we have another Pro but
let's check out of here first century
404 great you're there see if you can
free me from that console probably not
though it's incredibly advanced alien
technology no way some kid good workers
Oh God keep going I think you're on to
something what happens if I do it wrong
[Music]
keep going I think you're onto something
I understand where this game got
censored now I know I could trust you
keep it up I'm still stuck better try
the other console Nakao mine alright
let's get a head over here then what is
this nope space [ __ ] O'Shea and with in
here oh god oh god I got an inch oh god
that is the worst okay let's try the
other console god I hope this works
everywhere
[Music]
let's try this thing I don't know what
is uh-huh use Jack nice nice so I'm
teleporting for my [ __ ] that's that's
only something I wanted to do all right
here we go
can't touch this okay
maybe again MooMoo Manny look so sexy in
that outfit how do I kill that might be
circumcised oh yes yes cutting up aliens
dicks the Mongolian bow is Sophie all
right well that that takes care of them
I guess that's where I get stuck in the
dumbest places oh I can just walk oh
come on
now this again nice oh [ __ ] really
really the elevator so what's over here
miss Texas out first more audience nice
how do we get rid of that you can try
that room across the bridge deal is
really tough so be careful to remember
to use electricity electricity I don't
have any spell oh [ __ ] okay okay let's
prepare
yeah that's [ __ ] great of [ __ ] he's
so fabulous
goddamn ooh oh damn
yes the power of moe
what would have thought all right well I
have the power of Hungarian that's a
very nice face still though you have
there sir would be a shame if something
happened to it
no [ __ ] way
[Music]
hey that's pretty good
there we go all right now let's get rid
of the debuff by drinking [ __ ] water
like are the aliens in on this game or
whatever is this epiphany hopefully now
we can shed on them I mean oh damn
though you may be fabulous but I'm
doomed man gorian and you don't [ __ ]
with that
whoo all right let's finish that [ __ ]
and undermine Gordian mostly takes mana
to do that that's cool that makes sense
again [ __ ] yeah awesome it is a bit
challenge it's not like the most
difficult game in the world but it it's
enough to make a charm now let's say
fans dad hey did it the force fields
down come on back and we can get out of
here
so I realize now that a lot of people
are probably gonna have a problem with
you
little okay let's see what nice map
alright now we can go down here and say
- yes I love these come on yes hi is it
German
[Music]
a ginger alien space Hitler that's what
you get space Hitler that's what you
[ __ ] get that was the weirdest side
boss I have ever [ __ ] seen man
seriously but there was nothing else
down here do I need to fart on this
problem no I guess we saved Sam's dad or
whatever I think you made it okay use
this panel here and we can all go home
it's [ __ ] weird man
[Music]
oh you did it
I've got the crystal laughs thanks kid I
don't know who you are or if you're real
but consider me your friend
yeah I'm Alka until we meet again so so
this is some kind of weird YMCA alien
space Club that does okay actually it's
probably better if we don't read into it
too much all right we got the white
power quested new message okay I wanna
check that out
hey they hey there's an elevator in the
hallway to the right of the room where
we're trapped in you can you said okay
thanks Randy there we go
I got to use my alien probe - excellent
I have a feeling the mastermind behind
this is gonna be weird man tinfoil hat
just to be safe
a nine-year-old aha
okay that's cool I bet it's good shape
it's a stream all right let's [ __ ] these
guys at my block ten only made them burn
awesome no way they were we need a big
help fortune cookies sorry
I can't really do oh damn that's awesome
set to kill mu mu a [ __ ] okay be ready
oh he's almost dead we could actually
kill him
I want a circumcised why not seriously
oh sorry
moo moo moo-moo-moo and our woman you're
welcome oh so fab
[Music]
so what the [ __ ] are those things oh the
goo is everyone gonna become hit no
[ __ ] weird thought man oh yeah I
remember him
yes at what location how many people in
the town get in there and cover it up
this could change everything get
everyone moving we've got another UFO
crash another all right what do you know
it's me again the episode is over but
I'll see you tomorrow that would be a
great time to leave a like if you want
to watch the next episode click here
unless it's not out yet 24 hours you
know this is saying every thousand
breasts thank you for watching